♪ Four and three
and two and one.
- [Group] Yaaa!
(farts)
- There's only one Ilana Wexler.
- Straight up gorgeous.
- We run this city.
I often see things
other people don't.
Ding-dong.
You must be Matt.
- All my friends call me Bevers.
(coughs)
(cheers)
(cackles)
(hands slapping)
- Shania Twain.
(bleep) you and your
Mahattan restaurantaries.
- You're hired.
- Would you like
a puff of my wand?
It's pretty magical.
- Maybe I am changing.
- This place is magical.
- Good afternoon.
(gun shoots)
- [Group] Ahhh!
- Stupid, stupid!
- Ahhhh!
- Owww!
Ewe.
We got to go somewhere else.
I'm, I'm sorry.
(wooo)
(bleep) you,   (bleep)
I'm going back in. (sighs)
- [Abbi and Ilana] Whooo!
(screams)
(laughs)
- Wheeee!
- Love ya.
- Yeah, I love you too!
- So you are like feeling it?
- Uh, yeah.
(hands slap)